Speaker 1: Back in early March, at the start of
the Russian invasion of Ukraine, I did a story
called Could Putin be terminally ill? And the
story? It garnered great interest about a quarter
of a million views on YouTube and other similar
number on Facebook. And as I said at the time,
it was a speculative story. We're trying to make
sense of an invasion that appears to make no
sense. Vladimir Putin's face was pudgy. Could he
be on steroids for some medical condition? Could
it be a reason for rambling and aggression? And
many of you agreed. Yeah, I mean, maybe it is, but
it remained quite speculative. There is now much
more pressing speculation about Putin's illness
after a new video of Vladimir Putin has been
released. We have this video, which we're putting
up on the screen. This was a meeting that Putin
had with his Defense Minister, Sergei Shoigu.
And in the video, Putin is visibly gripping the
table in front of him, apparently for support.
He looks pale. He looks bloated, even more
bloated than he previously looked. And he
grips the table for basically the entire 12
minute video that was released by the Kremlin.
And the idea is that he's gripping it to avoid
some kind of tremor or shaking from being visible.
But if he's doing this with his right hand,
if you look at his left hand in the video,
it is very shaky and moving around in what
some are describing as a kind of unusual
way. It doesn't seem deliberate. Putin's
kind of hunched back on the seat back,
and he's regularly tapping his toes in a way which
it might just be a tick. It could be indicative of
something parkinsonian. It could be a side effect
from a medication. Professor Eric Boosie, who's a
body language expert from Texas Tech University,
said the face looks clearly bloated and that there
is a general unhealthy appearance. And meanwhile,
the unconfirmed rumors about Putin being in
treatment for cancer continued to be published
by various media outlets. They are not confirmed.
But it's hard to argue at this point that Putin
seems healthy. Now, the Kremlin has denied
allegations that Putin's health is a problem,
but the speculation has included prostate cancer,
thyroid cancer, Parkinson's or something.
Parkinsonian tardive dyskinesia is usually
a side effect of medication wouldn't tell us
the underlying situation, but it's something
else that's being mentioned now. Why does this
matter? Well, it matters because circumstantially,
this relates to the invasion of Ukraine in that if
Putin were very ill, if Putin were terminally ill,
it almost would be more sensible that he might be
trying to go out in a blaze of erratic aggression
meant to reconstitute the Soviet Union and being
seen as a martyr for mother Russia. And as crazy
as that sounds. It makes more sense than just
like he decided to invade Ukraine, I mean,
it makes no sense in in in a
in thinking in a logical way.
Now this is one of those, you know, it's a low
probability, but high risk event if this is really
what's going on, if this is an erratic, unhinged
Putin on his last leg as far as his life goes, not
his political life. And he thinks, Hey, I'm going
to die soon. What's the downside to using nukes
if that's the state of mind that he's in? And
again, this is speculative, but it is fueling the
conversation again about. Is anybody thinking of
an assassination attempt? And as I've said before,
when we talk about intelligence for
high level Western countries, they are
supposed to present all options. And so without
saying anybody's thinking of assassinating Putin,
it is without a doubt that when intelligence
had sit down with heads of state,
they give every option. And so it is almost
a certainty that could it even be done
when it comes to assassinating Putin has been
discussed when we say all options are presented.
They present all options. So newfound
questions about Vladimir Putin's health.
He doesn't look good. Will we ever really
know the truth? I have absolutely no idea